well good evening seven weeks today
fresh from his knockout win over dillian
white in front of 94 000 spectators at
wembley the heavyweight champion of the
world tyson fury looked me and looked
you in the eye and announced to the
world he was not going to fight again
well let me tell you something pierce
morgan uncensored this is the truth the
gospel truth nothing but the truth i'm
done
you know every good dog has its day and
like the great roman leader said
there'll always be somebody else to
fight when is enough enough i'm happy
i'm healthy i've still got my brains i
can still talk i've got a beautiful wife
i've got six kids i've got obtained
belts i've got plenty of money success
fame glory
what what more am i doing it for
well this morning in the sun newspaper
tyson gave a little hint
that it may not be
completely out of the question that he
might come out of a time for a reported
200 million pound fight to unify all the
titles so what's changed i'm glad to say
that tyson is joining me with the
beautiful wife paris that he talked
about in our last interview good evening
to both of you
good evening pierce hello there now
tyson i've got one question to ask you
when you looked me in the eye
those weeks ago yeah you vowed you were
never ever going to fight again
did you mean it yeah
yes
yeah
so you're not gonna fight again
no i still mean it piss
so when you're not gonna be fighting any
more professional fights i'm finished
what happens if the joshua usually fight
in august in saudi arabia is a bit of a
thriller and joshua wins
and the jungle drums begin beating but
the whole of britain wants to see you
finally get in a ring with anthony
joshua and frank warren being the
brilliant promoter that he is
puts a check on the table in front of
you
for such a gargantuan summer money you
think you know what i've got one bit of
unfinished business and it's joshua
no you know i don't care who wins out
the fight i wish i'm both luck in the
world
um i'm done i told you i was done seven
weeks ago i meant it there's some talk
of me having some exhibition fights but
to be honest with you i can't see that
coming off either um i've got no real
interest in fighting anymore um
it's not just the fight on the night
it's all stuff in the gym taking punches
to the head it's just enough is enough
for me um i put a ridiculous number on
today i said i'll come back for half a
billy half a billion pounds that's 500
million so if that's not ridiculous
ridiculous enough to believe i'm not
coming back for boxing i don't know what
is but somebody and franklin warren is a
good provider
somebody might get
somebody might get that number for you
they might get that number for you if
they do
if they do if they say
would you take it
yeah
listen i would definitely look at it if
there's half a billion on the table just
look at it you'll have to look at that
offer just have a look so
paris are for billy well let me come to
your wife who i suspect you know
probably wears the the rings in this in
this marriage
paris
how would you feel because i know after
the wilder trilogy he vowed he wasn't
going to fight again and you well you
believed him and he did then fight again
well after the first fight
yeah do you think he means his first
fight wilder i begged him not to fight
again and then he obviously fought on
and he had the trilogy and then he's
fought again just the other day in
wembley and he says he's definitely
quitting and he's definitely finishing
on top but
there's just still a glint in his eyes
that i see and i just i just don't know
i'd like him to retire everybody in his
family we're all happy with everything
he's done and he's just obviously he's
done amazing but
i just
don't know there's something in the back
of my mind that thinks tyson's still
itching for certain fights he's saying
this
we're here honestly this is why and he
tells me no and i would love to believe
it
but i'm just not quite there i think i'm
with the rest of the public thinking is
it true you see paris this is why i
wanted you in this interview because the
wives always know tyson if it was just
me and you i'd be taking all this at
face value but the woman you love
who you live with who knows you better
than any person alive
she sees that glint in your eye and she
thinks there's unfinished business
okay i'll ask her a question while
you're on paris yeah do you want me to
fight again for any amount of money no
yes or no no 100 million or 200 million
change our lives not at all but when
have you done what i've asked you to do
he always does what he wants to do he
will only do what he wants to do whether
it pleases me him or everybody he's only
going to do what he wants to do and what
if i said i'm not going to fight i said
to frank warren i've told bob arum i've
told everybody tyson fury and fighting
is finished
the money is not tempting to me to be
fair
um
but there's something still calling you
out there because the other day you were
saying oh i want to do expeditions i
don't i might do this and i might do
that you train every day like a crazy
trojan yeah but i do train for mental
health and emotional fitness and
everything else but the fact of the
matter is
i might might do an exhibition
exhibitions are not real fights to just
pretend play time showtime entertainment
but there's still something calling you
there and i just wonder you never know i
i hope you retired and i hope it stays
that way but it's one of them
we'll wait and see it
i'll have to wait do i have to stay out
the ring before i'm officially retired
then i don't know i think he was retired
for 10 minutes on box right wasn't he
well i've been out of the ring before
for three years
three years and i came back now tyson
i've never said never but it tyson we're
just gonna we've got a slight issue with
your microphone so i'm gonna talk to
paris and we're going to go full screen
with paris here while we fix your mic
and then we'll come back to you because
paris parish is actually doing a
brilliant job on my behalf getting the
truth out of you so we're going to come
just to paris for a moment apparently
yeah
and we're going to fix tyson's might
while we do okay
what i want to talk to you about you
first met tyson when you when you were
what age
uh 15 15 years old 15 i was pierced
you've had a remarkably uh
long successful not always perfect
marriage
to somebody who is i think one of the
most unique people i've ever met in
sport
uh uniquely smart uniquely
uh you know had his troubles always talk
so openly about them what's it been like
to be with tyson all this time and how
have you seen him evolve
um tyson has always been up and down and
always been this crazy lovable person
that he is and he's evolved in the fact
that i think he's matured which i do
think all men take a little bit longer
to do and he is now
happy and content in his life and i
think that's why he's retired i think
that's why in his heart and soul he's
happy with everything he's done and the
career went great everything that he
ever wanted to do and told me all them
years ago even as a young boy at 15 or
16 he told me i'm going to be
heavyweight champ of the world i didn't
really believe it i didn't didn't
believe that he couldn't do it i just
thought he'd probably get picked up in
other things um but tyson has done it
and i think he's happy and contented
which has made our life just brilliant
and everything's running really well
we've got six healthy children we're
happy and we're doing great so
to tick all the boxes he's done that
and
he's contented with his career and his
life of what he's done but
as the wife i just
i just look and i just wonder are you
doing as much as everyone else and i
hope he is i hope that with like
boxing's done and he chooses another
path and finds something that he's
passionate about and carries on with it
but
will he stay out the ring i honestly and
we're sitting here together and whatever
whatever we say afterwards but i do
think there's a question mark there
i do too we're gonna take a short break
when we come back i'll be back to you
tyson with some more tough questions on
piers morgan uncensored
you